hdan is speaking from Hamas let's listen
in of the word thats the sism and
fascism of this occupation this sadism
that has gone beyond all limits all
values all morals
all uh Celestial uh religions the sadism
also reflects the worst brutality in the
history of all
Humanity theion occupation is looking to
establish a security belt along the
borders of the Strip by leveling entire
residential blocks and by bulldozing
farms and civilian uh infrastructure
however this is a crime and this is a
blatant um aggression against our land
and our holy places these operations
will not succeed in accomplishing the
enemy's objectives because our people in
our resistance will foil these plans
with their resilience and their Jihad
Washington has once again called upon
the Zionist occupation to protect
civilians relief um staff as well as
facilities being owned and operated by
humanitarian organizations in Gaza since
the beginning of the aggression however
this is mere Hollow propaganda it is
even cheap propaganda that has no impact
whatsoever in the midst of the
continuing support backing and complete
partnership between this Administration
and the Zionist entity in his war in its
war of genocide against our people
because it is Washington that is feeding
the Zionist military killing machine by
providing it with munition and military
equipment that is being transported via
an air bridge and a maritime Bridge so
far at least 230 flights have been
conducted to transport equipment and 20
container ships have Saed sailed from
the United States to the Zionist entity
transporting equipment the last
aggression yesterday against the hona
training center in Kanan yunas which was
uh set on fire and the American silence
Vis this attack only goes to confirm
what I just said after that the massacre
that was committed today at the Kuwait
roundabout when Ana called upon idps to
come and collect relief Aid only for
them to be bombed by Zionist strikes
leaving over 30 murderers and 150
wounded people and this is another crime
to be added to this record of the United
States and its partnership with the
occupation the continuing
International silence and uh lack of
action in the face of these crimes of
genocide is actually tent amount to
collusion and can only be viewed as
complete surrender to the Zionist
terrorism being supported by the United
States
second as far as the battlefield and the
political area are concerned our people
and our resistance have shown great
resistance and the men of our brigades
the murder aadin alasam brigades the AL
brigades as well as the Palestinian
resistance all these men are waging
heroic Feats that will remain written in
the history of our people and the
history of all Humanity the last of
which is the Glorious operation of al-
mahaz where Al
soldiers surprised the Nazi occupation
soldiers and scored a number
of uh kills and injuries and the real
numbers are much larger than those that
were announced by the occupation we are
proud of our heroic resistance
particularly the Victorious alasan
brigades as well as the alud brigades
and every single Palestinian resistance
faction in this pivotal battle and we
thank God and praise Allah because only
Allah has enabled
our in order for them to continue
to provide these historic Feats and
everybody has seen what happened in al-
magazi where a single shell inflicted
such great losses upon our enemy for you
did not throw but it was Allah who
through as it says in the Quran praise
be to Allah first and foremost and we
hope that Allah the almighty will
continue to enable and assist Our Heroes
on the
battlefield and
addition are people in the Gaza Strip
men young men women Children and
Families they continue to wage a
historic Battle of resilience they are
standing as a single man and words fail
to describe the epic battle and the Epic
heroism that they are exhibiting in
spite of The Killing In Spite of the
massacres in spite of the starvation in
spite of The Thirst in spite of the
systematic shelling that is targeting
every facet of life our people are still
resilient they are still holding fast
they are still challenging the enemy and
we've all seen the
scene we've all seen how uh the
commanders of the Zionist Army are
treating each other and this shows
internal dissensions this shows
confusion usion amongst these criminal
leaders both political leaders and
military leaders we have seen their
differences we have seen how they are
unable to accomplish any of the
objectives that they set out to
accomplish and their war of aggression
and here we would like to reiterate very
clearly that as the resistance continues
to manage this battle with prowess with
wisdom and as it continues to deliver
great results and as it continues to
control the flow of this battle in order
to avenge the blood of the Martyr defend
our people and Stave off the aggression
we are once again proving that we are
taking serious steps towards a clear
Victory against this Nazi enemy thanks
to Allah the resilience of our great
people in the Gaza Strip and them
holding fast on their territory and
offering great sacrifices continuing to
stand fast for months on end and them
rallying around their resistance and
embracing their resistance with faith
and power are actually the rock upon
which all the plans of the occupation
will come crashing down including
displacement violations of the rights of
our people and our people's dignity and
identity the failed criminal
Netanyahu is delusional and believes
that by continuing his war of genocide
against our people he will accomplish
one or some of his objectives and the
plans that he's seeking to accomplish in
Gaza however he will come out
empty-handed and Gaza will be the
cemetery of his dreams his delusions his
plans and his army God
willing failed Netanyahu continues to
lie to his people he continues to sell
them delusions without caring about the
numbers of his soldiers who are falling
every day and without caring about the
lives of the soldiers and officers of
the occupation Army who are being held
by the resistance he continues to
arrogantly drag his feet and play for
time and this policy will only lead to
more losses that will translate in his
political future God willing we are
dealing very seriously with the
proposals and the ideas being put
forward by mediators regarding putting a
complete and comprehensive end to the
aggression and reaching a compreh ensive
prisoner swap however here we reaffirm
that the only opportunity for the
soldiers being held by the resistance to
be returned alive to their families will
not come until a comprehensive and
complete end of the aggression being
waged against our people and foot
dragging and playing for time will only
mean more dead and more death in the
ranks of these captives as a result of
the continued aggression against our
people and those who responsibility for
that are Netanyahu the criminal and the
commanders of his army as well as the US
Administration which is an accomplice to
the crime that is being committed
against our people they also bear
responsibility they are fully respon
responsible for the continuation of this
war of genocide its repercussions its
results and this war that will only
bring them more despair more losses and
then will will make them appear in court
to stand trial for their aggression and
their crimes once their political and
Military future comes crashing down
third international
stances I will start with the
international court of
justice the Hamas movement is following
with great attention the discussions
taking place within the international
court of justice following the lawsuit
that was uh put forward by the
government of South Africa in order to
put an end to the war of genocide
against our people in the Gaza Strip in
light of this The Stance of the Hamas
movement is actually built on the
principles of reciprocity and
international law represented in the
following three points
here first off if the court in the ha
decides to enforce a ceasefire the Hamas
movement will commit to the ceasefire as
long as the enemy commits as well
second the Hamas
movement will release the Zionist
detain it is currently holding if the
occupation State releases Palestinian
detainees being held in Israel all
Palestinian detainees being held
third the enemy must put an end to its
blockade I mean the Zionist entity must
put an end to his blockade that has been
going on for 18 years against the Gaza
Strip and must allow for the complete
and unobstructed entry of all relief aid
for our people in the Gaza Strip as well
as all the necessary requirements for
reconstruction after the destruction
that was swn by the enemy in the Gaza
Strip in the same context we call upon
all governments all countries all
humanitarian organizations in the world
to continue to file lawsuits in the
international court of justice and the
international criminal court against the
Zionist occupation as well as its
political security and military leaders
in order to bring to light their acts of
aggression and present them to trial as
war criminals we also call call upon
them to ramp up lawsuits against Zionist
officials in all countries and all
capitals of the world that they're
visiting in order for us to prosecute
the leaders of this fascist entity in
order to expose this entity and bring to
light its Act of aggression against the
whole world and an example is what
happened recently in Switzerland the
lawsuit that was brought forward against
the criminal the president of the
Zionist entity Herzog who was signing
the shells being launched by Zionist
artillery and airplanes against our
people and killing our women and
children
The Continuous attacks by the criminal
Netanyahu and the Nazi ministers and
extremists against our Arab and Islamic
countries the last of which was their
attack on the brotherly state of Qatar
only shows political bankruptcy and
failure in the face of all the criticism
that they are facing internationally and
in the face of them being held
responsible for the repercussions of the
war of genocide being waged in the Gaza
Strip and this behavior that they're
exhibiting goes to show the fact that
Netanyahu and his government do not care
about the vital role that qar has played
and continues to play as an honest and
effective mediator in the negotiations
that will hopefully lead to an end of
the aggression and a prisoner swap
actually this position is an attempt to
escape or sidestep the the effort
seeking to put a complete end to the
aggression and reflects the Deep crisis
that netanyahu's Army is experiencing in
the field we also salute the position
of
Egypt that has declared its refusal of
all Zionist plans to uh occupy the
Philadelphia Crossing uh point and we
call upon Arab and Islamic countries to
support these stances and make every
possible effort to put an end to the
aggression to Aid our people and support
their resilience on their territory and
make sure that they bring in all the
help that our people need through the ra
border crossing despite the refusal of
the occupation and
here I would like to address some of the
things that some of the uh solutions
that are being put forward by Zionist
leaders particularly in
Europe whether the proposal by the
Minister of Foreign Affairs the genius
Minister of Foreign Affairs about the
establishment of an artificial Island at
Sea that our people will be forced to go
and live and and live on these proposals
as well as all other proposals to
receive our people in other countries
only reflect the fascist and Nazi
mentality of the Zionist occupation that
continues to dream to take our people
out of their land these delusions these
dreams will never came true will never
come true they will never become reality
our people are standing fast in their
territory like Mountains and the
occupation will end God willing and
these Invaders will come back to whence
they came from the four corners of the
world and here we would also like to
reaffirm that we reject
the uh proposals of Mr John
Kirby as well as other statements that
were made by us Administration officials
about the day after the aggression in
the Gaza Strip and that the future of
the Gaza Strip cannot include the Hamas
movement this statement is a blatant
interference in our people's Affairs and
a continuation of the hemony through
which the US Administration seeks to
maintain control over people's decisions
and choices we believe that this
behavior is yet another form of
aggression that we refuse an aggression
against our people we are a main
component of the Palestinian people and
our people are the only decision makers
when it comes to choosing their
leadership and deciding their
fate once again we praise the honorable
stance of our
brothers in Yemen who continue to Target
ships belonging to or headed to the
Zionist entity and support to Palestine
Jerusalem and Gaza and in solidarity
with the resistance in the Gaza Strip
until the end of the Zionist aggression
in this
context
we regard with condemnation and we warn
of all efforts that are seeking to save
the Zionist entity from the IC defeat it
is currently suffering in the Gaza Strip
as expressed by the fascist Minister
Mari
regev when she spoke about uh building a
road that will be used to transport
goods from India to Arab territories
through Arab territories and then to the
Zionist entity in order to uh circumvent
the blockade that was imposed by the
Yemen Armed Forces against ships headed
to the Zionist entity and here we would
like to say very clearly that Arab
countries concerned with the statement
that was made by this extremist criminal
are actually required to clarify their
stance regarding the statement that she
made because
today we are standing we are waging a
historical battle a battle that has no
room for half Solutions and have stances
we call upon our Arabic and Islamic
people and the free people of the world
to continue to ramp up all efforts and
all forms of solidarity across the board
and with all available means in every
city and every capital of the world to
expose the occupation to reject its
crimes and to express solidarity with
our people and our just cause until the
Zionist aggression has ended we once
again call upon them all to take to the
streets tomorrow Friday as well as
Saturday and Sunday and raise their
voice across the world in order to put
the failed criminal Netanyahu is
delusional and will come out
empty-handed from Gaza the words there
of a defiant senior member of Hamas
hamdan speaking in Beirut he went on to
say his organization has taken a stance
towards the icj ruling with three
principles Hamas will accept a ceasefire
and abide by it as long as the enemy
does he said Hamas will release
detainees if as he put it the Zion State
releases Palestinian detainees and he
said the Zionist entity must end the
blockade of 18 years he went on to point
at the United States saying it was
engaging in blatant interference in our
people's Affairs and another form of
aggression through the proposals of John
Kirby which he said we reject the
National Security CC ccil spokesperson
of course